Mitt Romney is considering a run for the
Senate raising the question would he be
more of an ally or an adversary a
president Trump Romney delivered a
scathing speech during the 2016
presidential campaign calling then
candidate Trump a phony and a fraud that
was just the nice stuff who's been
playing the American public for suckers
but our next guest who knows both men
pretty well says Romney is no never
Trump er Ronnie McDaniel is both
Romney's niece and the chairwoman of the
Republican National Committee Rhonda
it's great to see you thanks for coming
in tonight
always good to be here okay so what's
what's MIT can do this is the big
question number one
so my advice I'd scoop I don't ask him
what he's gonna come on I cannot so I
can come on shows and say I have no idea
I don't even have small ad I'm not fun
on that front but I will say my advice
to any Republican is spend your time
focusing on the Democrats look at
Schumer look at Pelosi look what they do
if they were holding the reins of this
country where our country would be today
focus on them stop focusing on the
Republicans I always say if you have a
problem in your family don't go on Jerry
Springer and this president's doing a
great job we should be supporting him
but he did send out this tweet right
after the S hole controversial comment
controversy he said the poverty of an
aspiring immigrants nation of or origin
is as irrelevant as the race the
sentiment attributed to POTUS president
is inconsistent with America's history
and antithetical to American values may
our memory of dr. King Bowie our hope
for unity greatness and chariot of all
that was a dig at the president Rana
well we've seen many different accounts
come from this meeting the president has
said it's been totally misrepresented I
take the president's word at that so
you're taking the president over uncle
met president was in the meeting so yeah
I take the president's word at what he
said he's representing himself and he's
talking about better immigration better
borders focusing on things that are
going to help make this country safer
and great again you know I keep thinking
of the senators and congressmen who
opposed Trump who happened to be
Republicans it hasn't worked out so well
for the main Boehner is gone you know he
was kind of middle more but you know
flake is on his way out corker was kind
of in and out he's gone I mean I don't I
don't see the play here like oh I'm
gonna be a never Trump er okay
I mean but I don't even know where that
gets you so what are you gonna be
against lower unemployment jobs a better
economy I mean look at where our country
is a year into this Trump administration
we are humming we're on the right track
this is a president everyone should be
getting behind I hope Democrats all hear
the word and start supporting this
president as well now this is what Chuck
Schumer I know you were up watching The
Late Show last night Ronnie you were
just glued to your TV this is what
Schumer said to Colbert let's watch he's
not a racist well he's the least racist
police traces person you would ever
speak to all time so I have a challenge
for Donald Trump okay act actions speak
louder than words you want to begin just
begin that long road back to proving
you're not a racist you're not bigoted
support the bipartisan compromise that
three Republicans and three Democrats
have put on the floor everyone gave and
get the dreamers safety here in America
by the way Rhonda that's just the first
step toward Trump's Redemption so give
everything I want to the Gang of Six and
then he'll have a teeny baby step toward
not being a racist thanks Chuck exactly
well I'm sure Chuck Schumer is the
person the president's listening to
right now I'd say to Chuck Schumer why
don't you take some advice from yourself
20 years ago when you voted for a wall
when you said we needed to fix
immigration when you recognized that we
had a border issue maybe Chuck Schumer
should go revisit his past self and
support some of the things that the
president's putting on the table that
it's gonna make our country safer now
the Democrats keep saying well I got all
these vacancies retirements they're
probably gonna get wiped out in the
house gonna lose you could lose the
Senate in the house I mean they're going
into the full full you know wish list
here but they like the Republicans are
toast
what's the real scoop you thing well the
RNC's don't sugarcoat it the RNC's raise
record money
we know that the midterms of the first
term brutal usually are usually brutal
we've been ready for it we're in 22
states we have the best data and ground
game we're ready to compete and we have
an economy that's doing well we've got
accomplishments to run on we've got a
president that's leading the way I don't
think it's gonna be what the Democrats
hope but I want our base energized so go
ahead worry get out there be engaged
volunteer we have a national day of
training on Saturday on the first
anniversary of this people have
immigration
get out you you you cannot rest this is
gonna be that type of election card that
we're gonna have to work as hard as we
can to me keep majorities okay you know
I always ask you this yes you do I want
the comments most frequently made on the
return envelopes when people asked when
you asked for money send out mass
mailings people write do this don't do
this what's the most common thing so I
got my homework done today pretty good
so we have had actual record low dollar
fundraising in jail which is the number
one thing that people are saying on the
phones and on the mail is we need to
keep our majority in Congress because we
need to support this president so it's
not even us soliciting donations we
actually have people calling because
they're so concerned we are beating 2016
2014 any other election year in small
dollar donations because our basis so
they want the wall built they don't want
to just do an estate amnesty we get
support this president support is agenda
Ron are great to see you thank you
thanks for coming in